living in New York and feel like you're
constantly bombarded with stressful
sounds 24 7.
so can sounds like these
[Music]
help with Stress Management and anxiety
to get answers I went to a university
lab to get hooked up to a brain
recording device feels good and tracked
my heart rate at a sound bath in
Brooklyn
during sound baths or sound meditations
a facilitator like Matan chalvit plays
instruments
[Music]
oh
so the idea is to really listen to the
instruments trust yourself
and let go
for the nearly two hour group session
Matan told us to move as little as
possible
that was actually easier than I
anticipated
[Music]
there is never same feeling there is
never the same trip it's always
different it kind of felt ominous and
and scary but then also like really
grounding and that was
unexpected but nice
to understand the science behind how
music affects the brain and body I drove
up to Yale University in New Haven
there I'm at Aza also a musician and
neuroscientist who studies the effects
of Music on the brain
some of what sound baths are actually
tapping into as well is this idea of
meditation it's
sort of getting your mind into a place
that is more still Asia Hamilton told me
that music helps us get into a
meditative State more easily
what about music facilitates that some
of it we think is the actual physiology
so the fact that your heart rate is now
slowing down your breathing is slowing
down when you have these very long sort
of tones during my sound meditation
Matan played tones that lingered for a
long time and that were bright and Light
this was among the lowest my lowest
heart rate so I know I hear a lot of
longer
higher frequencies some Studies have
found that sounds like bees stimulate
the parasympathetic nervous system it's
a network of nerves that helps run
involuntary bodily functions like
digestion when the activity of the
parasympathetic nervous system increases
blood pressure and heart rate go down
and you feel more relaxed
during my visit I tried out a session of
aza's online music mindfulness study in
his participants he's seeing lower
levels of perceived stress
I was surprised that I also felt calmer
and more relaxed here even though the
setting wasn't as soothing as the yoga
studio
but music can also be intense and bring
up unsettling emotions the harmonics are
a little bit more dissonant there's a
little bit more tension there
[Music]
which is involved in our fear response
we feel that emotion we might cry or
have some sort of cathartic experience
aca's brain Imaging research is trying
to decode what kinds of music can
improve our mental health and under what
circumstances one of his initial
findings is that certain kinds of music
facilitate social connection which can
also relieve stress and have positive
health benefits Aza and his team hooked
me up to dozens of brain activity
sensors to test music's effects on brain
activity and how connected I felt to
another person
I'm all hooked up in this case head of
the brain function lab neuroscientist
Joy Hirsch
we felt most connected when we were
listening to harmonious music like this
and looking at each other
that's in part because the temporal
parietal Junction an area that helps
with social information processing is
more active
and it's less active when the music is
dissonant
[Music]
feeling connected is important because
isolation is a growing mental health
problem 58 of Americans say they're
lonely that figure is even higher among
Hispanic and black adults for whom Aza
and other experts say there are big
unmed mental health needs
one barrier to accessing sound
meditation sessions and their potential
benefits is cost the other is time
but research shows that even a few
minutes of pairing music and mindfulness
can help
foreign